una estrategia de tiempos de guerra yo
wyden dedicó su primer día completo como
presidente de eeuu a presentar un plan
federal para combatir el kobe 19 las
medidas incluyen la activación de la ley
de producción de defensa para acelerar
la fabricación de mascarillas jeringas y
otros insumos una prueba pcr y 40 y no
obligatoria para quienes viajen al país
y el uso obligatorio de más caricias en
aeropuertos y en la mayoría de los
transportes las acciones llegan cuando
según el propio presidente eeuu podría
alcanzar los 500 mil muertos el próximo
mes y las cosas continuarán empeorando
antes de mejorar el año pasado no
pudimos confiar en el gobierno federal
para actuar con la urgencia el enfoque y
la coordinación necesarias y hemos visto
el costo trágico de ese fracaso
josh de hartsfield la estrategia marca
un contraste con la administración de
donald trump que privilegió las
respuestas a nivel estatal una
diferencia por la que anthony fauci dijo
sentirse aliviado una de las cosas que
haremos es ser completamente
transparentes abiertos y honestos si las
cosas van mal no apuntaremos con el dedo
sino que corregiremos y todo lo haremos
basados en la evidencia científica
ene efe el gobierno de bailén apunta a
administrar 100 millones de dosis en los
primeros 100 días para contrarrestar el
frustrante inicio de la campaña de
inmunización por la falta de suministros
la vacunación sufre severos retrasos uno
tiene que estar en casa tranca o con no
bebe para no cosa en la calle y
ahora viene que no al menos está mal o
está mala cosa que se ponga el gobierno
la pela que se ponga a trabajar para que
no nos muramos todo porque nos vamos a
morir en más de un mes se han
administrado sólo 17 -cinco de las 37 9
millones de dosis disponibles de las
vacunas de facer y modernas